ici on va avoir un espace d'initiation
au golf la plaine de chemin cour
transformée en lieu de loisirs après
trois ans de réflexion avec ses
concitoyens le maire de magny les
hameaux bertron où lyon a défini ce
projet on va voir aussi un espace
d'athlétisme pour tout ce qui est donc
pistes pour tout ce qui est show est
lancé qui situera donc juste derrière le
car en football et en lien aussi avec
avec l'espace de golf un gymnase un
terrain de football et un parcours santé
existent déjà sur cette plaine bucolique
mais la mairie souhaite accueillir plus
de monde
elle va créer 60 places de stationnement
et les manies quoi pourront profiter de
tables de pique nique et de jeux pour
enfants
notre objectif est d'en faire un lieu de
loisirs un lieu de sport et puis un lieu
finalement très familiale de détente de
rencontre de partage plus de 2,6
millions d'euros c'est le coût de ce
projet d'aménagement il est financé
notamment par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
la région et le département après un
appel d'offres lancé en mars
les travaux devraient commencer cet été
ouverture prévue dès cet automne